[Music]
all right
um i'll make you feel better i'm going
to make you feel better
oh ever since i started working
i quit i qualified anymore
i don't want to be an entertainer
anymore lily sling
so i i want to play this because why i
hate you but also
how many people like you know from
youtube just retire and go off on the
sunset before they
themselves are become drug addicts both
downs
so i'm just kidding what's worse you
doing
um you know what man i'm gonna call the
clubs see if they look for a dj
[Music]
so uh tony do you need me back
i could be back to work by thursday this
is um
lily singh now we have seen her do her
monologues
um we have seen her interview people
we've seen her do skits
you know what we haven't seen her just
sitting at the desk and riffing
remember when carson used to sit there
and he used to do the envelope thing
that bit he did the swami yeah the great
kresgen it was great it was good
but it was great right it was one of the
funniest bits and everybody
jay leno would have the news clips like
hey look look at this look at this crazy
new thing
uh everybody had the year 2000 the
falcone and everybody had something
right the top 10 list
letterman well lily singh has her own
thing and i think it's going to blow the
top 10 list out of the water
ever since i started working on this
show i feel like people keep saying
things to me
when they really mean something
completely different does that ever
happen to all y'all
no like they'll say things like hey lily
i love your show but they really mean
like i don't know
i'm gonna get fired if i don't like your
show yeah so i love your show
like i'm going to help you break down
what they really meant with one of my
favorite new segments
said it meant it
look she still by the way people now
have only been picking up on the
something to punctuate the joke the body
motion that you were pointing out last
time or the
or the ah she's so
not confident in her own writer's
attitude
she didn't even do this in her old
youtube videos no
[Music]
even the graphics for this show
everything is so it all looks like it's
from fiverr
terrible you're right fiverr exactly a
bunch of indians are doing this
do you remember again going back to the
old shows
you like look at carson and you look at
like letterman or leno the amount of
money that went into making that look
like a good show
it's not like the musician that the sh
the shitty house band on those shows
were bands that if they weren't the
tonight show band they would have been
like a major label band like these were
you know what i mean they got conan had
springsteen's drummer they had
they got the best of the best for things
and just
you know it's like i don't know get some
indians on fiverr to make some [ __ ] and
i don't know who cares
what they said was hi friend what they
really meant was
i have no idea what your name is
that's the joke
i don't like that she's doing the camera
change angle when uh
like when uh what's his face
fact i always forget his name keenan
keenan thompson would do the al
sharpton yeah and he'd be like over
there now moving on
to the next segment also over
they did that [ __ ] so well that the
camera changes
what they said was can i borrow your
charger
what they really meant was i'm going to
take your charger and i'm never going to
give it back
is she reading tweets from 2010 this is
a joke
that's the joke i'm not giving your
charger back
dude i like
i have this theory
seven day theory michael valley i have
this theory that
what if what if right the deep state and
the globalist what if they're
actually trying to save mankind
opposite by making wokeness and
globalism
so unpalatable that even normies are
like i can't
i won't do this what if the whole goal
what if the deep state really is the
good guys and they're like we're gonna
make nationalism hot again
but we gotta we're gonna have to go
through a rough like six or seven years
it's gonna get very weird and
everybody's like i'm in and now even
normies are like i don't get it
i don't get her like i don't get her i
don't get the
nobody gets this there's nobody talking
about her in a positive way
no there isn't well that's not true the
bots the bots but they're
where is the p where is it is there any
is there one youtuber that's like i like
lily sing
let me um well i mean uh probably phil
the franco
girls and yeah phil defranco wants to
check clearly since i started working
i was refreshing because i was going to
no
we're not starting no no i'm not a man i
was i was just refreshing to check out
the comments
okay i can't do this okay so i haven't
okay let's see
well i bet no other late night host
exits like this that's so lily
316 upvotes but only five replies
this has 3 000 likes and 77 dislikes
uh let's uh they're deleting comments
now by the way so let's
let's go back where we were at the funny
joke here it was what your name is
can i borrow your charger okay here we
go what they really meant was
i'm going to take your charger and i'm
never going to give it back
too real that's how you lose friends i
can't
dude bro like literally dude like the
other day dude like the other day
elizabeth came over and she was like
dude can i borrow your iphone
don't talk like that and i'm like bro
bro like yeah you could like borrow it
too like
literally that's how you lose friends
mediocracy dude
we're becoming idiocracy you're right
you're right
you talk like and your shit's already
yeah girl yeah i'm gonna get that yeah
yeah
i could wait forever thousand dollars
and then you know
yeah i could wait forever girl
[Laughter]
why rudolph so underrated man so what do
you think i don't know like bowls of
fruit
[ __ ] like that she's the best
[Laughter]
too real that's how you lose friends
wearing a bra kill you like i get that
you're trying to be
like feminist or whatever but can we can
we wrap can we wrap those bad boys up
i can't you always lie and say you don't
have a charger come on
look at her set we haven't really seen
her desk set yet
it looks like
a polygon is she sitting on a polygon
she looks like she's sitting on on like
like a rebooted version of the
bridge from the enterprise yeah you know
what she looks like or no no a borg
like a borg vessel her set looks like
when you're playing a game but the
graphics haven't caught up yet it hasn't
fully rendered
what they said was as we discussed
what they really meant was you're 100
wrong and i already explained this but i
guess i have to walk you through it
again
where's the punchline what's the
don't know i don't joke
that level of passive aggressiveness is
what i strive to be true
she talks in memes no no no for real
like i'm not even
every late night host whether you like
them or don't like them they come up
they have their own kind of flow their
own style whatever their own thing fine
she everything she says is a meme or
something that was shared on tumblr
you know she doesn't have any original
thoughts any original like this
uh that that this level of petty like
you've you've seen yeah
like oh my god yo real feels right there
exactly you know what i mean like oh my
god me
like just it's just literally
uh it's everything like girl i can't
believe she's not gonna say i feel
personally attacked
she will really okay what they said was
can i see a picture of your baby what
they really meant was
can i show you a picture of my dog
that's a great [ __ ] about and she's
beautiful look how beautiful she is
ugly oh she's beautiful
this is she's lovely isn't she lovely
because she has a picture of her dog bro
[Applause]
what they said was i want to apologize
for doing brown face
what they really meant was oh
she's about to go there oh snap she's
about to go there
put pipe in the um here it comes
apologize for doing brown face
what they really meant was
i really hope you don't find the other
20 pictures of me in brown face
mike drop no seriously drop a mic
never pick one up again never go near
one again
i don't know it's finished
is she doing wacky faces right now for
her joke to land better
i think i'm gonna be sick i know i don't
feel good
mr stark i don't feel good
look at that i she did a wacky face did
you not see her wacky face
i'm glad you made a thanos reference
because like seriously fight with thanos
just
make me snap twice [ __ ] bye
look at her look women think that being
gross and being loud
is funny now let me show you that they
definitely buy this
buy these uh comments 137 i bet no no
other late night host exits like that
that's all lily
how did she exit did that yeah watch
that was her exit
we're doomed we're doomed
why because ten years ago people would
this would have been unacceptable to
everyone
if it wasn't so political everyone
wasn't so political yeah a lot of people
were going that doesn't really matter
this is terrible
her lipstick is everything she is
dropping looks and jokes and i love her
for that
lily is starting to be her relaxed
authentic self again that's what makes
the show
awesome go lilly fire emoji
what they said was enraging i just read
that come on let me read it
what they said lily ain't even funny
what they meant was
i can't fathom the fact that she made
this big kick and ass late night host
i still sometimes don't find colbert
jimmy trevor
uh funny in every episode at least uh
relatable
even i could go to reddit and predict
their trump jokes
within a week of following and don't
bring in bill burr paper tiger
and annette inspired comments here being
uh steady be strong and rise to the top
bdw we love that rap song from the
premiere videos and want to separate and
release that okay
this is a bot comment right this is a
very
it's structured this this is structured
like a bot comment you could tell right
uh everything that it's hitting on
because it's saying she doesn't even
joke about trump it's
too much in this comment to be real a
doctor a seem
to worry i bet it's a real person doctor
subscriptions leo george the daily show
a little late with lily singh the jim
jeffrey shows
late night with steve hold on hold on
this guy
only subscribes to shows
only subscribes to late night shows
jimmy kimmel v who subscribes to vevo
a bot this is a bot right yes
this this has to be a bot this can't be
a real person
doctor a scene don't worry
just right click and then google search
it i'm doing it no
you copied and paste you can highlight
yeah because hold on right click and
then it just opens up a tab
i mean unless there's two of them that
ain't the same guy
that's not the same guy right this is
the main one that's coming up
um nobody's buying this nobody
nobody is buying these comments nobody
3 000 upvotes 77 down votes that that
can't be right right
there's no way that's only 77 people
out of the 49 000 that saw this went
this is really funny
i don't believe you well let's see let's
go to newest first because that's before
they delete them
this is worse than the chevy chase show
hey sweet d
chill with the sound effects
people who find this funny should be
studied in the name of science
where are the jokes danny saint what i
said this sucks
what i meant women were mistakes
i have the feeling that this show would
be pushed to a more early time slot
because it's a mega hit
ps i get the old lily vibes from this
episode
i don't get it
the lightning needs to be brighter
everything else is amazing
not funny not clever and worse not
original nbc please improve wardrobe
budget for lily the way that wasn't a
shot that wasn't somebody being nice
trying to be nice and failing